pero algunos días efectivamente el
discurso de ayer de tronos parecía un
discurso de campaña y tocó el tema
migratorio
básicamente volviendo a tocar el hecho
de que eeuu es un país que les debe
cerrar las puertas a los inmigrantes
supuestamente aquellos que le llaman los
ilegales
la política de bailén hasta ahora ha
sido una política de reabrir en los
brazos de eeuu tomando una una actitud
más de más comprensión hacia aquellos
que buscan asilo político en eeuu
también ha presentado un proyecto de ley
que le abriría el camino para los 11
millones de ilegales que están en este
país o mejor dicho los de penar palabra
es los indocumentados aquellas personas
para que puedan tener un camino hacia la
ciudadanía esa es propuesta de ley fue
presentada en el congreso y ahora
entrará en debate los republicanos se
oponen abiertamente a la propuesta pero
es un proceso de negociación que ya el
presidente va a ir en tomó el primer
paso ahora el expresidente donald trump
afirmó que la decisión de ello pretende
cancelar la seguridad fronteriza ha
lanzado por sí solo una crisis de
jóvenes migrantes que está enriqueciendo
a los contrabandistas y a los cárteles
criminales le pregunto si esta
afirmación es cierta
en la afirmación del dentro de que se ha
abierto el camino y que efectivamente
han incrementado el número de personas
que están entrando a la frontera se han
vuelto a abrir a aquellos campamentos
pero con la diferencia que se le está
dando entrada junto a los a los niños
junto con sus familias no se están
separando como se estaba haciendo en la
era de tron el país tiene que buscar una
forma de que de normalizar el proceso un
país no puede tener fronteras abiertas
quedó todo el mundo simplemente camine y
entré ilegalmente pero hay que hacerlo
de una forma justa y buscando el
bienestar de aquellas personas que
entran para agrupar puestos que ningún
americano está dispuesto a hacer y que
después permanece en el país y son
personas que no tienen derechos
ayudan y contribuyen en la sociedad con
sus impuestos por lo tanto si la
situación de la migración es necesaria
para la economía americana hay que
buscar la forma justa para aquellas
personas que entre
tengan beneficios sociales y que
eventualmente puedan ser ciudadanos de
otro país brevemente abogado otro hombre
aparece en un momento donde la
administración bardem tiene como
propósito unir el país y tratar de
mermar la violencia política cómo
influye este discurso de trump en su
base más radical
el discurso de tron fue catastrófico
para la unión de eeuu para buscar la
unidad es lo que está buscando es una
minoría dentro del partido republicano
que lo apoye ciegamente y que más lo
mantenga vigente en el campo político
el discurso del ayer fue un discurso
extremadamente divisivo volvió a legar
de que había sido le que le habían
robado la elección y propuso una cosa
que es la clave de todo esto lo más
importante del discurso mental desde el
punto de vista derecho que él pide que
las elecciones sean solamente un día un
día que las personas tengan que ir a las
urnas solamente aquellas personas que
estén seriamente enfermas que se les
permita votar y la razón de eso es que
el día martes es el día de las
elecciones en el país en un día donde se
puede controlar solamente a aquellas
personas que están en mejores posiciones
tienen el tiempo para ir a las urnas y y
de esa forma si limitas la elección a un
solo día
a millones y millones de trabajadores
que no puedan ir a las urnas ese día
trump está buscando una forma
autoritaria de que una minoría si rija
los destinos del país abogado gracias
por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 feliz día